so what's terraform why might you want
to use it to manage your own
infrastructure in this short you'll find
the answers to these questions
terraform is an open source
infrastructures code tool by hashicorp
that automates the building and
management of Google Cloud
infrastructure infrastructure as code is
a topic that deserves another video so
we've saved it for a different YouTube
Source in this series
with terraform infrastructure is
expressed as code in a language called
HCL terraform is commonly used to manage
infrastructure track and automate
changes and standardize configuration
to use terraform you first write your
infrastructure as code in configuration
files initialize to install provider
plugins terraform will then generate a
plan and execute it to build a described
infrastructure
terraform can then determine updates
that can be applied as your
infrastructure evolves
are you ready to learn more click on the
three dots and click on the link in the
description box to enroll in the getting
started with terraform for Google Cloud
course see you there